♪
♪ WELCOME TO HANNITY
TONIGHT.
END OF A WEEK OF A DECISIVE
WEEK OF WINS FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
IN A SPAN OF A FEW SHORT
DAYS THE PRESIDENT DELIVERED
THE MOST POWERFUL STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS I HAVE
WITNESSED IN MY ADULT
LIFETIME.
AND OH, YEAH.
THE IMPEACHMENT WITCH-HUNT
TOTALLY IMPLODES.
THE PRESIDENT EXONERATED
FOREVER PETTY PELOSI.
WHILE HER MONTHS OF THIS
LONG CHARADE CULMINATING
WHAT WAS A PATHETIC
NATIONALLY TELEVISED
PETULANT TEMPER TANTRUM.
THIS IS WHAT THE MODERN
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THIS THREE PLUS YEARS WITH
NONSTOP RAGE RESISTANCE.
WITCH HUNTS CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND LIES.
A FEW RIPPED UP PIECES OF
PAPER AND THAT’S IT.
NOW, PETTY PELOSI, WELL SHE
IS NOT EXACTLY A MASTER
STRATEGIST.
YOU CAN SEE AND WE WITNESSED
THIS WEEK SHE IS AN ANGRY,
BITTER, MUMBLING, BUMBLING
SORE LOSER AND LIKELY WILL,
IN FACT, GO DOWN IN HISTORY
AS THE WORSE SPEAKER OF
HOUSE THAT WE HAVE EVER
SEEN.
ONE THING IS A CERTAINTY
TONIGHT.
WE CAN SAY THIS.
HER DAYS AS SPEAKER ARE NOW
NUMBERED.
AND ONCE AGAIN, WE WERE
RIGHT ALL ALONG.
AND THE MEDIA MOB, OR AS
USUAL, WRONG AGAIN.
RAISING THE HOPES, THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THEIR
DWINDLING AUDIENCES.
YET, AGAIN, ONLY TO
DISAPPOINT THEM YET AGAIN
WITH MORE FAKE NEWS.
OF COURSE, THIS IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE, THE SCHUMER SCHIFF
SHAM SHOW WOULD END IN UTTER
FAILURE.
BUT THEY WERE RAISING THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THEIR, WELL,
SMALL AUDIENCE VIEWERS.
ANOTHER HUGE LOSER IN ALL OF
THIS WELL, THAT WOULD BE
QUID AND PRO AND QUO JOE.
AND HIS ZERO EXPERIENCED SON
HUNTER WAS BEING PAID
MILLIONS.
NOW, DESPITE THE ATTEMPTED,
HYPOCRITICAL, DOUBLE
STANDARD COVER-UP BY THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR ALLIES
IN THE MEDIA MOB, WE, IN
THIS PROGRAM, WERE CORRECT.
WE TOLD YOU THE TRUTH.
JOE, HUNTER, GUESS WHAT?
THEY ENGAGED IN NOTHING
SHORT OF WHAT WAS A SHADY,
SLEAZY, AND, YEAH, WE
BELIEVE CRIMINAL POTENTIALLY
ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR IN THE
COUNTRY OF UKRAINE.
WE WERE ALSO CORRECT THAT
UKRAINE INTERFERED IN THE
2016 ELECTIONS TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON.
DON’T BELIEVE ME?
LET’S LOOK AT THE
JANUARY 11, 2017
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT IN
POLITICO.
AND BY THE WAY, THAT
CONCLUSION ALSO CAME ABOUT
ELECTION INTERFERENCE BY
UKRAINE SEPARATE AND APART
FROM RUSSIA FROM A UKRAINIAN
COURT.
JUST LIKE WHEN WE WERE
CORRECT IN REPORTING THAT
HIGH RANKING GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ABUSED THEIR POWER
AND COMMITTED FISA ABUSE.
WE WERE RIGHT THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS ILLEGALLY SPIED
ON BY MEMBERS OF AN OPPOSING
PARTY AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
ELECTION WITH DEEP STATE
OPERATIVES BEHIND ALMOST ALL
OF IT.
WE WERE CORRECT THAT HILLARY
CLINTON, YEP, RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, SHE BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR THE DIRTY
UNFAVORABLE RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
WE NOW KNOW FULL OF A PACK
OF LIES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WAS
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA USED BY
THE DEMOCRATS.
EVEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
FINALLY GOT THE PICTURE AND
THEY POINTED OUT WE NOW HAVE
REASON TO BELIEVE AS THEY
SAID IT WAS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION ALL ALONG.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, WE WERE
RIGHT ABOUT THE DEEP STATE,
WHICH WAS CHOCKED FULL OF
TRUMP HATING OBAMA
HOLDOVERS.
TWO OF THESE ANTI-TRUMP
BREWER DEMOCRATS WERE
REMOVED FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
THANKFULLY EARLIER TODAY.
BOTH LIEUTENANT COLONEL
ALEXANDER VINDMAN AND HIS
TWIN BROTHER THEY WERE
ESCORTED OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE COMPLEX.
GOOD FOR THE PRESIDENT.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER
LIEUTENANT COLONEL VINDMAN
WAS TRASHING THE PRESIDENT
DURING HIS TESTIMONY IN THE
HOUSE AND REBUKED THE
ADMINISTRATION’S POLICY IN
UKRAINE.
MR. VINDMAN, YOU WANT TO BE
IN CHARGE OF FOREIGN POLICY,
WHY DON’T YOU TRY AND RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
THEN WE FIND OUT HIS TWIN
BROTHER WAS ASSIGNED TO THE
OFFICE THAT WAS VETTING
PUBLICATIONS FROM GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, LIKE JOHN
BOLTON’S BOOK.
ALTHOUGH AT THIS TIME WE
DON’T HAVE THE EVIDENCE THAT
HE HANDLED THE BOLTON BOOK,
BUT I HAVE MY SUSPICIONS.
IT IS CLEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS DRAINING THE SWAMP AND
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
WE HAVE BEEN RIGHT EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
THE MEDIA MOB HAS BEEN
WRONG.
NOTHING WE HAVE REPORTED HAS
EVEN REMOTELY BEEN
DISPROVEN.
WE NOW HAVE THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
THAT’S HOROWITZ’S REPORT
VINDICATING THE REPORTING WE
HAVE DONE FOR ALMOST THREE
STRAIGHT YEARS ON THIS
PROGRAM.
IT DOESN’T SEEM TO MATTER TO
THE RADICAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THEIR CO-CONSPIRATORS,
STATE RUN MEDIA MOB.
BUT THAT DOESN’T MATTER TO
THE RADICAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY
EITHER IN ANY WAY.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
TRUTH.
THEY ALL LIVE IN THIS
BUBBLE.
THEY NEVER QUESTION THEIR
OWN NARRATIVES.
THEY NEVER LISTEN TO
OPPOSING VIEWPOINTS.
MOST OF THEM PROBABLY DON’T
EVEN HAVE CONSERVATIVE
FRIENDS.
THEY HATE THIS SHOW.
BUT THANK YOU FOR MAKING US
NUMBER ONE.
WE WANT TO LIVE UP TO YOUR
EXPECTATIONS EVERY DAY.
AND TELLING YOU THE TRUTH
MATTERS.
MATTERS TO US.
COLLEAGUES IN THE MEDIA.
THEY DON’T SEEM TO CARE.
NOW, WE KNOW THAT THEY
FREQUENTLY MISTAKE THEIR OWN
FAR LEFT OPINIONS AS
UN12350U9EDUNDISPUTED FACTS.
THEY ACTUALLY SAY IN THEIR
OWN HEADS THEY ARE
JOURNALISTS.
THEY ARE NOT JOURNALISTS IN
ANY WAY, SHAPE, MATTER OR
FORM.
THEY ARE BLIND SIDED BY ALL
THEIR FAILURES AND
PREJUDICES AND POLITICAL
POINTS OF VIEW.
THIS IMPEACHMENT SHAM IS BUT
THE LATEST EXAMPLE AND BY
THE WAY IT WAS NEVER GOING
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND TODAY THE PRESIDENT
POINTED OUT THE CHARADE IS
NOW COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
AND UTTERLY DEAD AND
MEANINGLESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY SHOULD BECAUSE IT
WAS A HOAX.
THAT’S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
SHOULD THEY EXPUNGE THE
IMPEACHMENT IN THE HOUSE?
THEY SHOULD BECAUSE IT WAS A
HOAX.
IT WAS A TOTAL POLITICAL
>> Sean: YEP, THIS LATEST
IMPEACHMENT HOAX MIGHT NOW
BE IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR
BUT THE LYING, THE SMEARS,
THE BESMIRCHMENT, THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THEY
NEVER END.
JUST TODAY THE PRESIDENT
SCORED A MASSIVE VICTORY IN
THE COURTS.
WE HAVE A THREE-JUDGE PANEL
UNANIMOUSLY THROWING OUT A
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT BOUGHT BY
200 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THEY LOST AGAIN.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT SICK OF
WINNING.
THE SUIT ALLEGED THE
PRESIDENT WAS IMPROPERLY
PROFITING FROM HIS TIME IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE ACTUALLY LOSES MONEY BY
WORKING IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THE COURT RULED
LAWMAKERS DIDN’T HAVE ANY
LEGAL STANDING TO PROCEED
WITH THEIR CLAIMS.
AND MEANWHILE RAGE FILLED,
DELUSIONAL DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKERS ARE NOW PRESSING
FORWARD WITH A HAVE A
VARIETY OF FRIVOLOUS
INVESTIGATIONS, ENDLESS
INVESTIGATIONS, MORE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
MORE TALK ALREADY OF
IMPEACHMENT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
A BRAND NEW EFFORT TO
SUBPOENA JOHN BOLTON.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
THIS IS NOT OVER.
NOW, THERE IS ONE WAY I HAVE
FIGURED OUT THAT YOU CAN END
ALL OF THIS.
THE NONSTOP LYING, THE
SMEARING, THE SLANDER, THE
BESMIRCHMENT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, WITCH HUNTS, THE
HOAX, THERE IS ONE WAY YOU
CAN DO IT, IN 270 DAYS YOU
WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
BY THE WAY, YOU DON’T EVER
HAVE TO WASTE YOUR TIME
WATCHING ANY FAKE NEWS IN
THE FUTURE.
CAN YOU TUNE THEM OUT LIKE
MOST PEOPLE ARE.
THE WAY TO STOP THIS FROM
EVER HAPPENING AGAIN AND
CONTINUING IN 270 DAYS, YOU
WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
YOU GET TO TAKE BACK CONTROL
OF YOUR COUNTRY.
NOW, IF YOU LIKE PRESIDENT
TRUMP, AND YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEE HIM BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
A LITTLE BIT OF PEACE AND
NOT HAVE THESE CONSTANT, YOU
KNOW, THREATS HANGING OVER
HIS HEAD, 24 HOURS A DAY,
EVERY DAY OF THE WEEK, WELL,
WHEN YOU VOTE FOR HIM, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO VOTE FOR
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN.
AND REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
TO THE DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS,
DO YOU REALLY THINK THEY
DESERVE YOUR TRUST?
AND BY THE WAY, IT’S NOW
MORE CLEAR THAN EVER THAT
THE TRUMP AGENDA AS WE SAW
ON TUESDAY NIGHT, A MASSIVE
SUCCESS.
DESPITE THE NEVER ENDING
NONSTOP RADICAL RESISTANCE,
OUR ECONOMY IS BREAKING
RECORD AFTER RECORD AND
BOOMING.
JANUARY JOBS NUMBERS.
GET THAT.
THEY BEAT ALL EXPECTATIONS
YET AGAIN.
A WHOPPING 225,000 NEW JOBS
ADDED.
EVEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES,"
THEY WERE FORCED TO ADMIT
WAGES FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS
IS ON THE RISE AFTER A
DECADE OF STAGNATION.
THAT WOULD BE UNDER
BIDEN-OBAMA.
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
CELEBRATED AMERICA’S
UNDENIABLE ECONOMIC SUCCESS.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS MORNING THE BRAND
NEW JOBS NUMBERS CAME IN.
WE SMASHED EXPECTATIONS AND
CREATED 225,000 NEW JOBS
LAST MONTH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
225,000.
THEY WERE THINKING MAYBE
100.
MAYBE 105.
I WAS WATCHING ALL THE
GENIUSES THIS MORNING ON
TELEVISION.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT’S GOING
TO BE?
IT’S GOING TO BE 110.
225.
PRETTY GOOD.
RIGHT?
225,000.
FOR LAST MONTH.
THAT’S ONLY LAST MONTH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: THAT’S 225,000 NEW
JOBS FOR OUR AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
HOW GREAT IS THAT?
A BOOMING ECONOMY, ONLY ONE
PART OF THE SUCCESSFUL TRUMP
AGENDA.
WE WILL SCROLL IT FOR YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
WE HAVE BEEN THE ONLY SHOW
ON TV APPARENTLY THAT EVER
DOES IT.
BUT ALSO UNDER THIS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, THE ISIS
CALIPHATE HAS BEEN
DESTROYED.
UTTERLY DISSEMINATED.
OH, ISIS LEADER AL BAGHDADI
AND HIS TOP LIEUTENANT, THEY
ARE ALL DEAD.
IRAN’S TOP TERRORIST, NUMBER
ONE STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR
LED BY THIS GUY SOLEIMANI.
HE’S DEAD, TOO.
AND NOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
CONFIRMED THAT AL QAEDA’S
TOP LEADER IN YEMEN WAS
KILLED IN A U.S. AIRSTRIKE
ORDERED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS,
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN AN
EFFECTIVE LEADER BY EVERY
MEASURE.
THE STATE OF THE UNION, WELL
IS REMARKABLY STRONG.
AND THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WELL, LOOK AT THEIR VERY
FIRST CAUCUS, AN UTTER
COMPLETE DISASTER.
YOU WANT TO TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT TO THEM THEY
COULDN’T EVEN RUN A CAUCUS
IN IOWA.
IT HAS TAKEN THEM THE ENTIRE
WEEK TO COUNT A FEW THOUSAND
VOTES AND THE RESULTS ARE
STILL RIDDLED WITHER WITH ERRORS
AND INCONSISTENCIES AND
NOBODY BELIEVES THEM ANYWAY.
A WAR IS ERUPTING INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS IS GETTING
ENTERTAINING.
ACCORDING TO A POLITICO
REPORT ELIZABETH WARREN
SUPPORTERS ACCUSING PETE
BUTTIGIEG FOR WHITE
PRIVILEGE FOR DECLARING
VICTORY IN IOWA.
BOTH WARREN AND MAYOR PETE
ARE LOSING TO SOCIALIST
BERNIE SANDERS IN A NEW
MORNING CONSULT POLL AND THE
DNC IS NOW LOOKING FOR NEW
WAYS WELL, TO RIG THE
PRIMARY ELECTION AGAINST
BERNIE YET AGAIN.
REMEMBER DONNA BRAZILE SHE
MADE THE PHONE CALL, SHE WAS
UPSET.
SHE DIDN’T WANT TO MAKE IT.
YEAH, THEY RIGGED IT AGAINST
BERNIE THE FIRST TIME.
NAU IT LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO IT AGAIN.
HIS CAMPAIGN IS ACCUSING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF CHANGING
THE RULES, WHICH THEY DID TO
ALLOW MIKE BLOOMBERG INTO
FUTURE DEBATES WITHOUT
MEETING FUNDRAISING
REQUIREMENTS YOU KNOW LIKE
250,000 UNIQUE DONORS.
BLOOMBERG WORTH AN ESTIMATED
$55 BILLION, WELL HE IS
PLANNING ON SPENDING MORE
THAN A BILLION TO BUY THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
NOW, HIS CAMPAIGN IS FACING,
TODAY, YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS
UP, PLAGIARISM CHARGES.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, 8
SEPARATE INSTANCES.
THE INTERCEPT FIRST REPORTED
THAT PASSAGES IN AT LEAST 8
OF BLOOMBERG’S POLICY
PROPOSALS WERE DIRECTLY
COPIED FROM VARIOUS MEDIA
OUTLETS, INCLUDING FAKE
NEWS, CNN, "TIME" MAGAZINE,
CBS.
OF COURSE HE WOULD BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE MOST
LIBERAL NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE COUNTRY.
IF THERE IS ONE THING MONEY
DOESN’T BUY, AND THAT’S
HONESTY.
I GUESS HE JUST FIGURES I
WILL TAKE WHAT THEY HAVE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT I BELIEVE.
I WILL SAY WHATEVER I NEED
TO BE.
IF I WERE A DEMOCRATIC
VOTER.
I THINK I WOULD FEEL
DISCOURAGED ABOUT NOW THE
PARTY IS IN COMPLETE
DISARRAY.
THE CANDIDATES ARE WEAK.
THEY ARE RADICAL, THEY ARE
UNINSPIRING.
THE PRESIDENT’S AGENDA IS A
MASSIVE SUCCESS.
IN 270 DAYS IT WILL BE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT WILL
DECIDE WHETHER WE CONTINUE
PEACE AND PROSPERITY AND
THAT MEANS ECONOMIC SUCCESS
AND THAT MEANS SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
OR DO WE WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO THE DEMOCRATS?
WELL, WE DID HAVE THE OBAMA
YEARS AND WE DID DROP
150 BILLION IN CASH AND
OTHER CURRENCY ON THE
TARMACS OF MULLAHS IN IRAN
THAT CHANT DEATH TO AMERICA.
WE DID, AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF
BIDEN-OBAMA HAVE 13 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ON FOOD
STAMPS.
8 MILLION MORE ON POVERTY
AND LOWEST PARTICIPATION
RATE SINCE THE 1970s.
YEAH, OBAMA-BIDEN
ACCUMULATED MORE DEBT THAN
ALL 43 PRESIDENTS BEFORE
THEM COMBINED.
BY THE WAY, FOUR THEY WANT